Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello, welcome to The Rest Is History. The story goes that in the year 860, the Chuds, the Slavs, the Krivichians and the Vests, people who live in what we now know as Russia, had fallen out among themselves, needed somebody to rule them. So they turned to the Vikings. Our land is great and rich, they supposedly said, but there is no order in it.
Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello, welcome to The Rest Is History. The story goes that in the year 860, the Chuds, the Slavs, the Krivichians and the Vests, people who live in what we now know as Russia, had fallen out among themselves, needed somebody to rule them. So they turned to the Vikings. Our land is great and rich, they supposedly said, but there is no order in it.|||感谢收听《历史的其余部分》（The Rest Is History）。要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先收听系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。您好，欢迎收听《历史的其余部分》。故事记载，在公元860年左右，楚德人、斯拉夫人、克里维奇人和维斯特人——这些生活在如今被称为俄罗斯的土地上的人们——彼此发生内讧，急需有人来统治他们。于是，他们向维金人求助。据说他们曾说：我们的土地广袤而富饶，但这里毫无秩序。
Come to rule and reign over us. And the person who accepted that offer was a man called Rurik, one of three brothers, Rurik, Sineas, and Truvor. Very close to Trevor, weirdly, Rurik, Sineus and Truvor. Very close to Trevor, weirdly. Rurik. You couldn't take a Viking chieftain. Seriously, Trevor. Rurik established himself in a place which we now know as Novgorod
Come to rule and reign over us. And the person who accepted that offer was a man called Rurik, one of three brothers, Rurik, Sineas, and Truvor. Very close to Trevor, weirdly, Rurik, Sineus and Truvor. Very close to Trevor, weirdly. Rurik. You couldn't take a Viking chieftain. Seriously, Trevor. Rurik established himself in a place which we now know as Novgorod|||来统治和主宰我们吧。接受这个请求的人是一个名叫留里克（Rurik）的人，他是三兄弟之一，另外两人是西涅乌斯（Sineus）和特鲁沃尔（Truvor）。说来奇怪，和“特雷弗”（Trevor）这个名字非常像，留里克、西涅乌斯和特鲁沃尔。跟特雷弗太像了，真奇怪。留里克。你没法把一个维金酋长当回事，特雷弗。留里克在如今被称为诺夫哥罗德（Novgorod）的地方站稳了脚跟
and his successors later moved to Kiev. And it's from that story that the countries of Russia, Belarus and Ukraine all trace their history. Tom, we did the origins of the Vikings in the East yesterday. Do you think there's any truth to this story at all? Well, I think the obvious parallel with this, if you are in Britain, is with the Dukes of Norm normandy which likewise has a kind of almost mythic origin story so it's rollo uh who is given this land by uh by the frankish king and all kinds of myths surround this figure i mean he he probably existed but he probably wasn't called rollo though was he no um tom shippy in his book
and his successors later moved to Kiev. And it's from that story that the countries of Russia, Belarus and Ukraine all trace their history. Tom, we did the origins of the Vikings in the East yesterday. Do you think there's any truth to this story at all? Well, I think the obvious parallel with this, if you are in Britain, is with the Dukes of Norm normandy which likewise has a kind of almost mythic origin story so it's rollo uh who is given this land by uh by the frankish king and all kinds of myths surround this figure i mean he he probably existed but he probably wasn't called rollo though was he no um tom shippy in his book|||他的继承人后来搬到了基辅。正因这个故事，俄罗斯、白俄罗斯和乌克兰三国才追溯各自的历史。汤姆，我们昨天探讨了东方维金人的起源。你觉得这个故事有哪怕一点真实性吗？嗯，我觉得如果你身处英国，最明显的类比就是诺曼底公爵（Dukes of Normandy），它同样有一个近乎神话般的起源故事——比如罗洛（Rollo），他被法兰克国王赐予了这片土地，各种神话围绕着这个人物。我的意思是，他可能确实存在，但他可能不叫罗洛，对吧？不。嗯，汤姆·希皮（Tom Shippey）在他的书中
about the vikings calls him ganga rolf which i think is a much better name uh yes um and all kinds of so there are all kinds of stories about how he he founds normandy and about how the original normans are not just vikings but they're people from you know all kinds of different backgrounds um and he establishes this duchy. And the question of whether, you know, William the Conqueror, the most famous of the Dukes of Normandy, is he a Viking? Is he French? You know, what is he exactly?
about the vikings calls him ganga rolf which i think is a much better name uh yes um and all kinds of so there are all kinds of stories about how he he founds normandy and about how the original normans are not just vikings but they're people from you know all kinds of different backgrounds um and he establishes this duchy. And the question of whether, you know, William the Conqueror, the most famous of the Dukes of Normandy, is he a Viking? Is he French? You know, what is he exactly?|||关于维金人的书中称他为“步行者罗尔夫”（Ganga-Hrolf），我觉得这是一个好得多的名字。是的。有各种各样的故事讲述他如何建立诺曼底，以及最初的诺曼人不仅仅是维金人，他们还来自各种不同的背景。他建立了这个公国。问题在于——比如诺曼底公爵中最著名的征服者威廉（William the Conqueror）——他是一个维金人？还是一个法国人？你知道，他究竟是什么人？
I think that that sheds a kind of really interesting light on the process of state formation in Novgorod, but even more particularly in Kiev. And obviously the background to this, as in the West, so in the East, it's about the way that the Vikings are moving into strange lands, establishing Viking polities that nevertheless take on the lineaments of the lands and the cultures and the peoples that they're settling among. Well, that's a very controversial subject though, isn't it? Because how much that's the case has been bitterly contested by academics.
I think that that sheds a kind of really interesting light on the process of state formation in Novgorod, but even more particularly in Kiev. And obviously the background to this, as in the West, so in the East, it's about the way that the Vikings are moving into strange lands, establishing Viking polities that nevertheless take on the lineaments of the lands and the cultures and the peoples that they're settling among. Well, that's a very controversial subject though, isn't it? Because how much that's the case has been bitterly contested by academics.|||我认为这为我们理解诺夫哥罗德，尤其是基辅的国家形成过程，提供了一个非常有趣的视角。很显然，这背后的背景——无论是在西方还是东方——都是关于维金人如何进入陌生的土地，建立维金政权，却又逐渐呈现出他们所定居的土地、文化和人民的特征。不过，这是一个非常具争议的话题，不是吗？因为这种情况究竟达到了什么程度，一直遭到学者的激烈争论。
How Viking are they? For those people who didn't listen to yesterday, I can't believe there was anybody who didn't listen to yesterday's podcast. But we did the sort of first hundred years. So the Vikings have been – I mean, Vikings is actually the wrong word because they're not really – The Rus. Yeah, the not really – The Rus. Yeah, the raiding.
How Viking are they? For those people who didn't listen to yesterday, I can't believe there was anybody who didn't listen to yesterday's podcast. But we did the sort of first hundred years. So the Vikings have been – I mean, Vikings is actually the wrong word because they're not really – The Rus. Yeah, the not really – The Rus. Yeah, the raiding.|||他们究竟有多“维金”？对于那些没有收听昨天节目的人——我简直不敢相信有人没听昨天的播客——我们讲了大约头一百年的历史。所以维金人一直在……我的意思是，“维金人”其实是个错误的词，因为他们其实不是……罗斯人。对，其实不是……罗斯人。对，进行劫掠的……
The Rus. The rowers. Have been coming largely from Sweden down the rivers from the Baltic and establishing this trading network, which is going to start to take on, as Tom said, it's not just the lineaments of the culture around it, but the lineaments of a state. And how quickly it does that is is again debatable so the sort of origin story that's told is that the which is very flattering by the way to the
The Rus. The rowers. Have been coming largely from Sweden down the rivers from the Baltic and establishing this trading network, which is going to start to take on, as Tom said, it's not just the lineaments of the culture around it, but the lineaments of a state. And how quickly it does that is is again debatable so the sort of origin story that's told is that the which is very flattering by the way to the|||罗斯人。划船者。主要来自瑞典，顺着波罗的海的河流南下，建立了这个贸易网络。正如汤姆所说，这个网络开始显现出不仅仅是周围文化的特征，还有国家的特征。它做到这一点的速度有多快，同样是有争议的。所以流传的这种起源故事，顺便说一下，非常讨好
scandinavian self-esteem it's you could say as a kind of slightly colonial story is that the surrounding peoples are so shambolic and kind of disorganized and backward they are falling out among themselves and they have to ask the vikings the roost to come in and rule them and there might be some element of truth in that don't you think tom that they that they might you know appeal to these armed guys in their trading posts to come and help them against a rival clan or a rival tribe and and that's how it starts do you think well i think it's it's failing the kind of the brute process by which i think pretty clearly what happens is that you you
scandinavian self-esteem it's you could say as a kind of slightly colonial story is that the surrounding peoples are so shambolic and kind of disorganized and backward they are falling out among themselves and they have to ask the vikings the roost to come in and rule them and there might be some element of truth in that don't you think tom that they that they might you know appeal to these armed guys in their trading posts to come and help them against a rival clan or a rival tribe and and that's how it starts do you think well i think it's it's failing the kind of the brute process by which i think pretty clearly what happens is that you you|||斯堪的纳维亚人的自尊心。你可以说这是一个略带殖民色彩的故事：周围的人民如此混乱、毫无组织且落后，他们彼此内讧，以至于不得不请求维金人（罗斯人）进来统治他们。你难道不认为这里面可能有一点真实成分吗，汤姆？他们可能会向据点里的这些武装人员求助，让他们来帮忙对抗敌对的氏族或部落，事情就是这样开始的，你觉得呢？嗯，我觉得这没有抓住那种粗暴的过程。我认为很明显发生的情况是：
as we said in the early episode you know these to begin with are trading ventures and so you have to have transit posts you have to have places where you can not just um do deals not just store things ready for when the rivers become navigable, but also to kind of pick up information. You can't survive without that. And we drew the parallel yesterday with trading posts in, say, Canada in the 18th century. But it's pretty clear that before long, these transit posts become forts. Yeah, wooden forts and once they've become forts then you can do what the vikings are doing in in um in the west as well
as we said in the early episode you know these to begin with are trading ventures and so you have to have transit posts you have to have places where you can not just um do deals not just store things ready for when the rivers become navigable, but also to kind of pick up information. You can't survive without that. And we drew the parallel yesterday with trading posts in, say, Canada in the 18th century. But it's pretty clear that before long, these transit posts become forts. Yeah, wooden forts and once they've become forts then you can do what the vikings are doing in in um in the west as well|||正如我们在早先的节目中所说，你知道，这些最初都是贸易冒险，所以你必须有中转站，你必须有这样的地方：不仅可以做买卖，不仅可以为河流通航储存物资，还可以收集信息。没有这些，你就无法生存。我们昨天将其与18世纪加拿大等地的贸易站进行了类比。但很明显，不久之后，这些中转站就变成了堡垒。对，木制堡垒。一旦它们变成了堡垒，你就可以做维金人在西方也在做的事情了——
which is basically to kind of set up protection rackets so what's been a cartel becomes a kind of mafia style operation yeah uh and you're charging protection money uh and if rurik existed and there is a kind of historically tested Rurik at around this time, I think, tested in Scandinavia, but whether it's the same person or not is debated. But if he existed, I think you could imagine him
which is basically to kind of set up protection rackets so what's been a cartel becomes a kind of mafia style operation yeah uh and you're charging protection money uh and if rurik existed and there is a kind of historically tested Rurik at around this time, I think, tested in Scandinavia, but whether it's the same person or not is debated. But if he existed, I think you could imagine him|||也就是基本上建立保护伞黑帮。所以原本的卡特尔变成了一种黑手党式的运作，对吧？收取保护费。如果留里克真的存在——而且据我所知，大约在这个时期确实有一个经过历史考证的留里克，在斯堪的纳维亚被考证过，但究竟是不是同一个人还有争议。但如果他真的存在，我想你可以把他想象成
as the kind of equivalent of a mafia boss. And then, you know, again, as happens in the West, Normandy being the obvious example, a protection racket becomes a state. Well, so we know so little about Rurik. We know that he established himself in Novgorod, which we talked about yesterday, and there's a statue of him to this day.
as the kind of equivalent of a mafia boss. And then, you know, again, as happens in the West, Normandy being the obvious example, a protection racket becomes a state. Well, so we know so little about Rurik. We know that he established himself in Novgorod, which we talked about yesterday, and there's a statue of him to this day.|||某种黑手党老大的存在。然后，正如在西方发生的那样（诺曼底就是一个明显的例子），保护伞勒索最终演变成了国家。好吧，我们对留里克的了解实在太少了。我们知道他在诺夫哥罗德立足，我们昨天谈到过这一点，直到今天那里都还竖立着他的雕像。
And this is the second half of the 9th century. Yeah, this is 860, I think it is, is it is it yeah about 860 to 862 are the dates given and so by the way we haven't really talked about sources this is coming from an incredible source called the russian primary chronicle which is as is so often the way written in the 12th century yeah exactly written at least 200 300 years later um by a monk called Nestor, I think, and is written in very different kind of political and cultural circumstances. So as with so much of early medieval history,
And this is the second half of the 9th century. Yeah, this is 860, I think it is, is it is it yeah about 860 to 862 are the dates given and so by the way we haven't really talked about sources this is coming from an incredible source called the russian primary chronicle which is as is so often the way written in the 12th century yeah exactly written at least 200 300 years later um by a monk called Nestor, I think, and is written in very different kind of political and cultural circumstances. So as with so much of early medieval history,|||这是9世纪下半叶。对，这是公元860年，我想是的，是吧？对，给出的日期大约是860年到862年。顺便说一下，我们还没怎么聊过史料来源。这出自一个了不起的来源，叫做《俄罗斯初年纪事》（Russian Primary Chronicle）。正如通常的那样，它写于12th世纪。对，没错，至少晚了200到300年。由一个名叫涅斯托尔（Nestor）的修士（我想是的）所写，而且是在非常不同的政治和文化环境下编写的。所以，和许多早期中世纪历史一样，
we just don't know whether these are legends, whether there is a grain of truth in them, whether it's retrospective kind of legitimizing. I think there must be a grain of truth in them, whether it's retrospective kind of legitimizing. I think there must be a grain of truth because I think that the, the idea of, of a kind of dynastic descent from Rurik becomes quite important. So, you know,
we just don't know whether these are legends, whether there is a grain of truth in them, whether it's retrospective kind of legitimizing. I think there must be a grain of truth in them, whether it's retrospective kind of legitimizing. I think there must be a grain of truth because I think that the, the idea of, of a kind of dynastic descent from Rurik becomes quite important. So, you know,|||我们根本不知道这些是传说、其中是否有半点真实性，还是事后追认的合法化叙事。我认为其中一定包含一丝真实性，无论它是否属于事后追认的合法化。我认为一定有真实的内核，因为我认为，自留里克以来的某种王朝世系的观念变得相当重要。所以，你知道，
if Rurik didn't exist, someone of the same name must have. But yeah, well, someone of the same, but, but the whole thing, Rurik and two brothers,
if Rurik didn't exist, someone of the same name must have. But yeah, well, someone of the same, but, but the whole thing, Rurik and two brothers,|||如果留里克不存在，也必然有同名的人存在。但是，好吧，同名的人，但是整件事情，留里克和两个兄弟，
I mean, all that sort of stuff. But there's clearly a dynasty established itself in Novgorod. Yeah. That will then expand. Yeah. So there's clearly a a dynasty establishing itself in novgorod yeah that will then expand yeah so there's two guys who are it says in the russian primary chronicle two men who do not belong to rurik's kin but were boyars that's the kind of russian they're basically um captains i don't know what the word is uh they're not nobles i mean nobles is the wrong word but they're sort of they're they're they're members of the gang, would you say?
I mean, all that sort of stuff. But there's clearly a dynasty established itself in Novgorod. Yeah. That will then expand. Yeah. So there's clearly a a dynasty establishing itself in novgorod yeah that will then expand yeah so there's two guys who are it says in the russian primary chronicle two men who do not belong to rurik's kin but were boyars that's the kind of russian they're basically um captains i don't know what the word is uh they're not nobles i mean nobles is the wrong word but they're sort of they're they're they're members of the gang, would you say?|||我的意思是，诸如此类的事情。但诺夫哥罗德显然建立起了一个王朝。对。随后它会扩张。对。所以诺夫哥罗德显然建立起了一个王朝，对，然后它会扩张。对，所以有两个人——《俄罗斯初年纪事》中记载，有两个并不属于留里克家族的人，而是波雅尔（boyars），那是类似俄罗斯的……他们基本上是……船长？我不知道该用什么词，他们不是贵族——“贵族”这个词不对，但他们某种程度上是……他们是帮派成员，你会这么说吗？
Soldiers, I guess is what Mafia knows and they basically go off they're called, the Russian primary chronicle has them as Askuld and Deer and as with so many of these names almost all the names we're talking about they're Slavicised versions of originally
Soldiers, I guess is what Mafia knows and they basically go off they're called, the Russian primary chronicle has them as Askuld and Deer and as with so many of these names almost all the names we're talking about they're Slavicised versions of originally|||士兵，我想这就是黑手党所理解的，他们基本上出发了，被称为……《俄罗斯初年纪事》中称他们为阿斯科尔德（Askold）和迪尔（Deer）。和许多这类名字一样，我们讨论的几乎所有名字，都是原本的……的斯拉夫化版本。
Norse names aren't they because I think they were huskulda and dury uh with the original my beautiful yeah absolutely impeccable old norse pronunciation there tom i hope you noticed they go off down the dnieper and they come to what they the chronicle says is a city on a hill again a little bit too kind of folk tale stroke biblical i think for anyway this place is kiev and it already exists uh been set up by somebody called key um hence the name yeah and askle and deer supposedly settle in kiev and say this is a great place i mean obviously it's a good place because it's
Norse names aren't they because I think they were huskulda and dury uh with the original my beautiful yeah absolutely impeccable old norse pronunciation there tom i hope you noticed they go off down the dnieper and they come to what they the chronicle says is a city on a hill again a little bit too kind of folk tale stroke biblical i think for anyway this place is kiev and it already exists uh been set up by somebody called key|||诺斯语名字，对吧？因为我认为他们原本是Haskulda和Dury，带着最初的——我那美妙的、绝对无可挑剔的古诺斯语发音，汤姆，希望你注意到了。他们顺着第聂伯河（Dnieper）而下，来到了纪事中所说的一座山丘之上的城市——说实话，这又有点太像民间故事兼《圣经》传说色彩了——无论如何，这个地方就是基辅，它已经存在了，是由一个名叫基伊（Kiy）的人建立的
further down the river further towards constantinople so it's kind of makes sense that they've established another fort stroke trading station that becomes their own little polity. And so the question of whether Kiev is Viking, which Putin's been worrying about this, so it's a topical question. But again, would you think that maybe there'd be a parallel perhaps with York? Jorvik. Jorvik.
hence the name yeah and askle and deer supposedly settle in kiev and say this is a great place i mean obviously it's a good place because it's further down the river further towards constantinople so it's kind of makes sense that they've established another fort stroke trading station that becomes their own little polity. And so the question of whether Kiev is Viking, which Putin's been worrying about this, so it's a topical question. But again, would you think that maybe there'd be a parallel perhaps with York? Jorvik. Jorvik.|||因此得名。是的，阿斯科尔德和迪尔据说在基辅定居下来，并说这是个好地方。我的意思是，这显然是个好地方，因为它更顺流而下，更接近君士坦丁堡，所以他们建立另一个兼作贸易站的堡垒，并把它变成他们自己的小政权，这是说得通的。因此，关于基辅是否是维金风格的——普京一直很关心这个问题，所以这是一个热门话题。但话说回来，你会不会觉得这可能与约克（York）有某种类比？约维克（Jorvik）。约维克。
You know, it's a pre-existing settlement, gets taken over by the Vikings, gets a Viking name. The Vikings rule it, and then they gradually get absorbed into the fabric of what, you know, returns to being an English city. But perhaps there's, I mean, the parallels are never exact, but there's something there of what's happening in the East as well as the West.
You know, it's a pre-existing settlement, gets taken over by the Vikings, gets a Viking name. The Vikings rule it, and then they gradually get absorbed into the fabric of what, you know, returns to being an English city. But perhaps there's, I mean, the parallels are never exact, but there's something there of what's happening in the East as well as the West.|||你知道，这是一个先前存在的定居点，被维金人接管，拥有了一个维金名字。维金人统治它，然后他们逐渐被融汇到——你知道的——重新变成一座英国城市的肌理中。但也许——我的意思是，类比永远不会完全精确，但东方发生的事情和西方发生的事情之间确实有某些相通之处。
Your parallel with Normandy was a really good one i think to people at the time sort of ninth tenth century people our attempts to fix labels on them would seem weird wouldn't they they would say well who cares i mean what what what's it to you what ethnicity that the concept wouldn't make an enormous amount of sense to them so the question of you know are they slavs are they scandinavian are they russians ukrainians i mean in a sense that they're it's a very very anachronistic question i mean what matters to them is who's who's got the weapons the power the money what they are is lads yeah absolute lads and they are but i don't think they're little bullingdon lads tom i think much more. No, they're much more predatory and brutal.
Your parallel with Normandy was a really good one i think to people at the time sort of ninth tenth century people our attempts to fix labels on them would seem weird wouldn't they they would say well who cares i mean what what what's it to you what ethnicity that the concept wouldn't make an enormous amount of sense to them so the question of you know are they slavs are they scandinavian are they russians ukrainians i mean in a sense that they're it's a very very anachronistic question i mean what matters to them is who's who's got the weapons the power the money what they are is lads yeah absolute lads and they are but i don't think they're little bullingdon lads tom i think much more. No, they're much more predatory and brutal.|||你对诺曼底的类比真的很好。我想对于当时的人们（9、10世纪左右的人）来说，我们试图给他们贴上标签的尝试会显得很奇怪，对吧？他们会说：“管他呢，关你什么事，什么种族不种族的”，这个概念对他们来说不会有什么巨大的意义。所以“他们是斯拉夫人、斯堪的纳维亚人、俄罗斯人还是乌克兰人”这个问题，从某种意义上说是一个非常非常时代错乱的问题。对他们来说，重要的是谁拥有武器、权力和金钱。他们是一群小伙子，绝对的小伙子。他们确实是，但我不认为他们是布灵顿俱乐部（Bullingdon）那种小伙子，汤姆，我觉得他们要凶猛得多。不，他们更具掠夺性和野蛮。
Because they, so Asgald and Deer, these pair of kind of Viking adventurers, the kin of Rurik, his descent, you know, his heirs, if they exist, they're moving in. Yeah. And they're like the kind of, you know, the bigger crime family moving in. And they take like the kind of, you know, the bigger crime family moving in. And they take over Kiev.
Because they, so Asgald and Deer, these pair of kind of Viking adventurers, the kin of Rurik, his descent, you know, his heirs, if they exist, they're moving in. Yeah. And they're like the kind of, you know, the bigger crime family moving in. And they take like the kind of, you know, the bigger crime family moving in. And they take over Kiev.|||因为阿斯科尔德和迪尔，这对维金冒险家，留里克的亲族、他的后代（你知道的，他的继承人，如果他们存在的话），正在搬进去。对。他们就像那种——你知道的——更大的犯罪家族搬进来了。他们就像那种——你知道的——更大的犯罪家族搬进来一样。他们接管了基辅。
And Kiev opens up the access to the Black Sea. And beyond the Black Sea lies Miklagard, Constantinople. Yeah, which we haven't talked about at all, which is enjoying some Renaissance, isn't it? Are we not in the Macedonian Renaissance at this point, Tom? So things are looking up for the Byzantines. Yeah, so they still think of themselves as Romans, don't they? They still call themselves the Roman way. They
And Kiev opens up the access to the Black Sea. And beyond the Black Sea lies Miklagard, Constantinople. Yeah, which we haven't talked about at all, which is enjoying some Renaissance, isn't. Are we not in the Macedonian Renaissance at this point, Tom? So things are looking up for the Byzantines. Yeah, so they still think of themselves as Romans, don't they? They still call themselves the Roman way. They|||基辅打开了通往黑海的通道。黑海之外就是米克拉加德（Miklagard），即君士坦丁堡。是的，我们还没怎么谈到过它，它正迎来某种文艺复兴，对吧？我们此时难道不是正处于马其顿文艺复兴时期吗，汤姆？所以拜占庭人的情况正在好转。对，所以他们仍然认为自己是罗马人，对吧？他们仍然自称为罗马人。他们
absolutely think we are Rome, and they have this massive city, they have tons of money, they're a very rich and sophisticated culture, and then one day, in the year 860, they kind of look out of the window and these, as you said, these lads have turned up in their ships. And the patriarch, the archbishop of nation of no account a nation ranked among slaves
absolutely think we are Rome, and they have this massive city, they have tons of money, they're a very rich and sophisticated culture, and then one day, in the year 860, they kind of look out of the window and these, as you said, these lads have turned up in their ships. And the patriarch, the archbishop of nation of no account a nation ranked among slaves|||绝对认为“我们就是罗马”，他们拥有这座巨大的城市，拥有海量的金钱，他们是一个非常富裕且高度文明的文化。然后有一天，在公元860年，他们往窗外望去，正如你所说，这些小伙子乘着船出现了。大主教，那位……无名小国的大主教，一个被列为奴隶之列的国家
unknown which has won a name from their expedition against us so basically well the shocking thing for the people of constantinople is that these utter nobodies who they regard as so far beneath them turn up and and um besiege their city and they keep doing this don't they and they they they seem to have very good intelligence because they invariably turn up when the imperial fleet is away. Yeah, or the emperor's off campaigning against somebody else.
unknown which has won a name from their expedition against us so basically well the shocking thing for the people of constantinople is that these utter nobodies who they regard as so far beneath them turn up and and um besiege their city and they keep doing this don't they and they they they seem to have very good intelligence because they invariably turn up when the imperial fleet is away. Yeah, or the emperor's off campaigning against somebody else.|||一个籍籍无名、却因对我们发动远征而名声大噪的国家……所以基本上，对于君士坦丁堡的人民来说，最令人震惊的是，这些被他们视为远在自己之下的绝对无名小卒竟然出现并包围了他们的城市。而且他们一而再再而三地这样做，对吧？他们似乎拥有极好的情报，因为他们总是在帝国舰队不在的时候出现。对，或者皇帝正忙着去讨伐别人。
So the walls of Constantinople are a great wonder. They are impregnable. But there are obviously all kinds of churches and monasteries, you know, as in England, that are kind of lying exposed. And the Vikings have all kinds of fun with them, don't they? They use monks as for archery practice. They nail hats on to the heads of priests and all kinds of badinage.
So the walls of Constantinople are a great wonder. They are impregnable. But there are obviously all kinds of churches and monasteries, you know, as in England, that are kind of lying exposed. And the Vikings have all kinds of fun with them, don't they? They use monks as for archery practice. They nail hats on to the heads of priests and all kinds of badinage.|||君士坦丁堡的城墙是一大奇迹。它们坚不可摧。但显然有各种各样的教堂和修道院——你知道的，就像在英格兰一样——暴露在外。维金人在它们身上找各种乐子，对吧？他们把修士当作射箭靶子。他们把帽子钉在神父的头上，还有各种各样的恶作剧和挖苦。
Very cool. So we have a question from, would you believe, Tom, we've got a question from Neville Chamberlain. Neville Chamberlain says, were there any attempts by the Vikings toings to take over byzantium in the same way they tried with england and ireland neville of course his reaction would no doubt be to to um to a piece far away country yeah which we know nothing um and my answer to that would be it's completely implausible they would ever take over constantinople there's one
Very cool. So we have a question from, would you believe, Tom, we've got a question from Neville Chamberlain. Neville Chamberlain says, were there any attempts by the Vikings toings to take over byzantium in the same way they tried with england and ireland neville of course his reaction would no doubt be to to um to a piece far away country yeah which we know nothing um and my answer to that would be it's completely implausible they would ever take over constantinople there's one|||太酷了。所以我们有一个问题来自——你敢相信吗，汤姆——我们收到了内维尔·张伯伦（Neville Chamberlain）的一个问题。内维尔·张伯伦问：维金人是否有过任何企图，想以对待英格兰和爱尔兰的方式去攻占拜占庭？内维尔的反应毫无疑问会是去安抚一个遥远的国家——一个我们一无所知的国家。我的回答是：他们根本不可能攻占君士坦丁堡。这里有——
of them isn't there who nails his shield to the gates of Constantinople as a kind of gesture of contempt because he obviously sees the walls as a kind of cheat. Yeah. But he knows that they're never going to break in. I mean, it's like saying, you know, will Paraguay ever defeat the United States and conquer its territory? I mean, it's just not a plausible matchup. So, Miklagar, the great city, it's not a plausible matchup um i think so so micklegard the great city it's it's
of them isn't there who nails his shield to the gates of Constantinople as a kind of gesture of contempt because he obviously sees the walls as a kind of cheat. Yeah. But he knows that they're never going to break in. I mean, it's like saying, you know, will Paraguay ever defeat the United States and conquer its territory? I mean, it's just not a plausible matchup. So, Miklagar, the great city, it's not a plausible matchup um i think so so micklegard the great city it's it's|||其中有一个家伙，不是吗？他把自己的盾牌钉在君士坦丁堡的城门上，作为一种蔑视的姿态，因为他显然把城墙看作某种作弊手段。对。但他知道他们永远不可能攻破城墙。我的意思是，这就好比说——你知道——巴拉圭有一天会击败美国并征服其领土吗？我的意思是，这根本不是一场势均力敌的对决。所以，米克拉加德这座伟大的城市，这不是一场势均力敌的对决。我想是的。所以，米克拉加德这座伟大的城市，它……
constantinople comes to kind of shimmer in the imaginings of all the vikings so much that essentially the the asgard the city of the gods comes to be equated with it yeah so that when they imagine what odin's halls look like they imagine it looking very like the golden city of caesar don't they don't they also tom um there are some people who think that when they talk about asgard or they talk about valhalla that images of hagia sophia the church of the holy wisdom um this incredible building the biggest building in the western world i guess at this point um which will come to yeah plays an important part in this story. The gold, the mosaics, just the sort of,
constantinople comes to kind of shimmer in the imaginings of all the vikings so much that essentially the the asgard the city of the gods comes to be equated with it yeah so that when they imagine what odin's halls look like they imagine it looking very like the golden city of caesar don't they don't also tom um there are some people who think that when they talk about asgard or they talk about valhalla that images of hagia sophia the church of the holy wisdom um this incredible building the biggest building in the western world i guess at this point um which will come to yeah plays an important part in this story. The gold, the mosaics, just the sort of,|||君士坦丁堡在所有维金人的想象中开始闪闪发光，以至于本质上，神之城阿斯加德（Asgard）开始与它画上等号。是的，所以当他们想象奥丁的大厅是什么样子时，他们想象它非常像凯撒的黄金之城。难道不是吗，汤姆？还有人认为，当他们谈论阿斯加德或瓦尔哈拉（Valhalla）时，圣索菲亚大教堂（Hagia Sophia，即圣智大教堂）的形象——这座令人难以置信的建筑，我猜是当时西方世界最大的建筑——将在故事中发挥重要作用。黄金、马赛克，那种……
that creates a lot of the images of, because the images that we have of Valhalla or Asgard all come later, don't they? They're all centuries after this. And they seem to kind of echo Constantinople. And I think the other difference, so there's no prospect of them capturing Constantinople. But I think also what the Byzantine Empire can exert, which England or Ireland or even the Frankish Empire can't do,
that creates a lot of the images of, because the images that we have of Valhalla or Asgard all come later, don't they? They're all centuries after this. And they seem to kind of echo Constantinople. And I think the other difference, so there's no prospect of them capturing Constantinople. But I think also what the Byzantine Empire can exert, which England or Ireland or even the Frankish Empire can't do,|||这构成了许多关于……的意象，因为我们对瓦尔哈拉或阿斯加德的印象都来自后来，不是吗？它们都在这之后的几个世纪。而且它们似乎在某种程度上呼应了君士坦丁堡。我认为另一个区别是——因此他们根本没有攻占君士坦丁堡的可能——但我认为拜占庭帝国能够产生的效果，是英格兰、爱尔兰甚至法兰克帝国所做不到的，
is to kind of generate this incredible cultural cringe. Because they, you know, every so often they're allowed, you know, it's actually with Constantine VII, isn't it? Who we mentioned in the previous episode, the emperor who describes this, the rapids that the Rus have to behave when they come and they're kind of bringing in their walrus tusks and their narwhal tusks and their amber and their beeswax and all kinds of stuff um and they're also providing for uh what becomes very famous uh a guard of what are called varangians yeah and and the varangian avar is a vow it's kind of the oath tak English. The oath takers, would that be? The oath takers.
is to kind of generate this incredible cultural cringe. Because they, you know, every so often they're allowed, you0 know, it's actually with Constantine VII, isn't it? Who we mentioned in the previous episode, the emperor who describes this, the rapids that the Rus have to behave when they come and they're kind of bringing in their walrus tusks and their narwhal tusks and their amber and their beeswax and all kinds of stuff um and they're also providing for uh what becomes very famous uh a guard of what are called varangians yeah and and the varangian avar is a vow it's kind of the oath tak English. The oath takers, would that be? The oath takers.|||那就是产生这种令人难以置信的文化自卑感。因为他们，你知道，每隔一段时间他们被允许——其实是在君士坦丁堡七世时期，对吧？我们在上一集提到过他，这位皇帝描述了罗斯人在到来时必须通过的激流，他们带来海象牙、独角兽角、琥珀、蜂蜡和各种各样的东西。他们还为后来非常著名的瓦兰吉安卫队（Varangian Guard）提供人员。是的，“瓦兰吉安”这个词源自誓言（vow），这是一种发誓的人。发誓的人，可以这么说吗？发誓的人。
And so they come to provide the emperor with his guard. And so the links, but essentially the Kievan Rus' start to be absorbed into the kind of the cultural tractor beam of Byzantine culture. Well, that's where I would say, Tom, I'm sure you, I don't think this is a controversial view at all. That's the point at which they stop being the Scandinavians who are known as the Rus, and they start becoming the ancestors of Russia. Yeah, of Ukraine and Russia.
And so they come to provide the emperor with his guard. And so the links, but essentially the Kievan Rus' start to be absorbed into the kind of the cultural tractor beam of Byzantine culture. Well, that's where I would say, Tom, I'm sure you, I don't think this is a controversial view at all. That's the point at which they stop being the Scandinavians who are known as the Rus, and they start becoming the ancestors of Russia. Yeah, of Ukraine and Russia.|||于是他们来为皇帝提供近卫军。因此这些联系……但本质上，基辅罗斯开始被吸纳进拜占庭文化的文化牵引光束中。嗯，这就是我要说的，汤姆，我确信你——我不认为这是一个有争议的观点。正是在那个时间点，他们不再是被称为罗斯人的斯堪的纳维亚人，而是开始成为俄罗斯的祖先。对，乌克兰和俄罗斯的祖先。
Yeah, because they're brought into the world of orthodoxy, of Byzantine church architecture, of all those kinds. They're beginning to kind of contract marriage alliances and trade deals and all this sort of stuff. And that brings them, you know, what do they care about what's going on in Norway? I mean- Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, because they're brought into the world of orthodoxy, of Byzantine church architecture, of all those kinds. They're beginning to kind of contract marriage alliances and trade deals and all this sort of stuff. And that brings them, you know, what do they care about what's going on in Norway? I mean- Yeah, yeah.|||对，因为他们被带入了东正教的世界、拜占庭教堂建筑的世界以及所有这些领域。他们开始缔结联姻和贸易协议以及诸如此类的事情。这给他们带来——你知道的，他们才不在乎挪威发生了什么呢！我的意思是——对，对。
And so by the mid 10th century, you get the first ruler of Kiev. I'm going to have a go at this, Sviatslav. So he's the first ruler to have- Sl'm going to have a go at this Sviatslav uh so he's the first ruler to have um Slavic name Slavic name but before him you've had various rulers who have more obviously Norse names so we had uh we had um uh Golden Deer with the guys who'd seized Kiev but then that gets seized from them by um a guy called Oleg that's right who is the guardian of Rurik's son Igor yeah so Rurik is definitely Scandinavian and Oleg is also definitely Scandinavian because Oleg that's right who is the guardian of Rurik's son Igor yeah so Rurik is definitely Scandinavian
And so by the mid 10th century, you get the first ruler of Kiev. I'm going to have a go at this, Sviatslav. So he's the first ruler to have- Sl'm going to have a go at this Sviatslav uh so he's the first ruler to have um Slavic name Slavic name but before him you've had various rulers who have more obviously Norse names so we had uh we had um uh Golden Deer with the guys who'd seized Kiev but then that gets seized from them by um a guy called Oleg that's right who is the guardian of Rurik's son Igor yeah so Rurik is definitely Scandinavian and Oleg is also definitely Scandinavian because Oleg that's right who is the guardian of Rurik's son Igor yeah so Rurik is definitely Scandinavian|||所以在10世纪中叶，你迎来了基辅的第一位统治者。我要试着念一下这个名字：斯维亚托斯拉夫（Sviatslav）。所以他是第一位拥有……斯维亚托斯拉夫，他第一位拥有……斯拉夫名字。斯拉夫名字。但在他之前，你们有过各种拥有更明显的诺斯语名字的统治者。所以我们有……我们有占领基辅的家伙们（阿斯科尔德和迪尔），但后来基辅被一个叫奥列格（Oleg）的家伙从他们手中夺走了。没错，奥列格是留里克的儿子伊戈尔（Igor）的监护人。是的，所以留里克绝对是斯堪的纳维亚人，奥列格也绝对是斯堪的纳维亚人，因为奥列格——没错，他是留里克的儿子伊戈尔的监护人，是的，所以留里克绝对是斯堪的纳维亚人
and Oleg is also definitely Scandinavian because Oleg which we always think of as a Russian name is actually Helgi I think yeah just like Olga is is Helga so Helgi or as we call him Oleg he's the guardian that's right he's the guardian of Igor and Oleg is a very impressive man generally he takes over Kiev he seizes it from Asgode and Deir. He leads another siege of Constantinople and gets a ton of money from sort of – so this is your parallel with the West, actually. He gets basically dangled from the sort of Byzantine authorities in 904. But he has a most – they have very good deaths, the Grand Princes of Kiev. So he has a most they have very good deaths the um the grand princes of Kiev so he
and Oleg is also definitely Scandinavian because Oleg which we always think of as a Russian name is actually Helgi I think yeah just like Olga is is Helga so Helgi or as we call him Oleg he's the guardian that's right he's the guardian of Igor and Oleg is a very impressive man generally he takes over Kiev he seizes it from Asgode and Deir. He leads another siege of Constantinople and gets a ton of money from sort of – so this is your parallel with the West, actually. He gets basically dangled from the sort of Byzantine authorities in 904. But he has a most – they have very good deaths, the Grand Princes of Kiev. So he has a most they have very good deaths the um the grand princes of Kiev so he|||而奥列格也绝对是斯堪的纳维亚人，因为奥列格——我们总认为这是一个俄罗斯名字——实际上是海尔吉（Helgi），我想是的。就像奥尔加（Olga）就是海尔加（Helga）一样。所以海尔吉，或者我们称他为奥列格，他是监护人，没错，他是伊戈尔的监护人。奥列格总体来说是一个非常了不起的人，他接管了基辅，从阿斯科尔德和迪尔手中夺取了它。他领导了对君士坦丁堡的又一次围攻，并从某种程度上获得了巨额财富——所以，这实际上就是你与西方的类比。他在904年基本上从拜占庭当局那里得到了好处。但他有一个极其……基辅的大公们死得都非常精彩。所以他有一个极其……基辅的大公们死得都非常精彩，所以他
has a very interesting death he has he's been told Oleg that um his favorite horse will be the cause of his death so do you know what um do you know what Oleg does Tom tell me he sends the horse away he says you know I don't want to to kill it because it's my favorite horse, but send it away and look after it, and I'll never have any dealings with it again. And after four years, in the year 914, he goes to visit the horse because he misses it so badly. It's so sad. He goes to visit the horse at the stables, and he's told by the stable hands,
has a very interesting death he has he's been told Oleg that um his favorite horse will be the cause of his death so do you know what um do you know what Oleg does Tom tell me he sends the horse away he says you know i don't want to to kill it because it's my favorite horse, but send it away and look after it, and I'll never have any dealings with it again. And after four years, in the year 914, he goes to visit the horse because he misses it so badly. It's so sad. He goes to visit the horse at the stables, and he's told by the stable hands,|||有一个非常有趣的死法。奥列格曾经被告知，他最喜欢的马将是他致死的原因。你知道吗，嗯，你知道奥列格做了什么吗，汤姆？告诉我。他把马送走了。他说，你知道，我不想杀它，因为它是我的最爱，但把它送走好好照料，我再也不和它有任何瓜葛了。四年后，即公元914年，他去探望这匹马，因为他太想念它了。太悲伤了。他去马厩探望这匹马，马夫告诉他：
well, the horse is dead. And he says, ha, ha, he says you know cheated fate those astrologers were absolute muppets you know i i've cheated death exactly and he says um bring to show my contempt for these these soothsayers bring me the skull of the horse so they bring him the horse's skull and he stamps on it. He's shouting, the horse is dead, but I am still alive. I was supposed to receive my death from this skull. And he stamps on the horse, on the horse's skull. And at that point, a snake crawls out from the horse's skull, bites him and he dies. There you go.
well, the horse is dead. And he says, ha, ha, he says you know cheated fate those astrologers were absolute muppets you know i i've cheated death exactly and he says um bring to show my contempt for these these soothsayers bring me the skull of the horse so they bring him the horse's skull and he stamps on it. He's shouting, the horse is dead, but I am still alive. I was supposed to receive my death from this skull. And he stamps on the horse, on the horse's skull. And at that point, a snake crawls out from the horse's skull, bites him and he dies. There you go.|||“马已经死了。”他说：“哈哈，你知道吗，我欺骗了命运，那些占星家简直就是一群白痴，我知道，我死里逃生了。”接着他说：“为了表示我对这些预言家的蔑视，把那匹马的头骨拿来给我。”于是他们把马的头骨拿给他，他用力踩在上面。他大喊着：“马死了，但我还活着！我本该死在这个头骨上。”他在马的头骨上狠狠踩了一脚。就在那时，一条蛇从马的头骨里爬了出来，咬了他一口，他就这样死了。就这样。
So the very act of defying the prophecy is what kills him. But. Yeah. So he was guardian for eagle yeah so eagle then is um so eagle takes over eagle has an even better death he yeah he has a very unfortunate death doesn't he so so eagle is eagle is the guy who negotiates the treaty with constantine the seventh because he's attacked them and being seen off with greek fire hasn't he yes that way at first yeah greek fire yeah which is what which is he? Yes, he has. That way he first used Greek fire. Yeah. Which is what?
So the very act of defying the prophecy is what kills him. But. Yeah. So he was guardian for eagle yeah so eagle then is um so eagle takes over eagle has an even better death he yeah he has a very unfortunate death doesn't he so so eagle is eagle is the guy who negotiates the treaty with constantine the seventh because he's attacked them and being seen off with greek fire hasn't he yes that way at first yeah greek fire yeah which is what|||所以，正是这种公然违抗预言的行为害死了他。但是。对。所以他是伊戈尔的监护人，对。然后伊戈尔是……伊戈尔接管了。伊戈尔的死法更精彩。他……他的死非常不幸，不是吗？所以伊戈尔是那个与君士坦丁堡七世谈判条约的人，因为他攻击了他们，结果被希腊火（Greek fire）击退了，对吧？是的，起初是这样的。对，希腊火。那是什么？
Well, he does besiege Constantinople. He doesn't just attack with ships. He actually tries to take the city twice. Yeah. And basically, he's a very, very kind of expansionist guy. So he's also, it's in his reign that they all go off and plunder all the kind of Muslim cities on the Caspian Sea. Oh, yes, that's right. They go to Azerbaijan, don't they?
Well, he does besiege Constantinople. He doesn't just attack with ships. He actually tries to take the city twice. Yeah. And basically, he's a very, very kind of expansionist guy. So he's also, it's in his reign that they all go off and plunder all the kind of Muslim cities on the Caspian Sea. Oh, yes, that's right. They go to Azerbaijan, don't they?|||嗯，他确实围攻了君士坦丁堡。他不仅用船只进攻，他实际上尝试过两次攻占这座城市。对。基本上，他是一个非常有扩张欲的人。所以也是在他的统治时期，他们所有人出发去掠夺里海（Caspian Sea）上的所有穆斯林城市。哦，对，没错。他们去了阿塞拜疆，对吧？
They go to Azerbaijan. So he's all over the place. I mean, he's very keen on kicking sand in people's face. Yeah. And one of the people that he kicks sand in the face of is a people called the Drevlians, or Slavic people, and they capture him. They pull down two birch trees, and they tie him
They go to Azerbaijan. So he's all over the place. I mean, he's very keen on kicking sand in people's face. Yeah. And one of the people that he kicks sand in the face of is a people called the Drevlians, or Slavic people, and they capture him. They pull down two birch trees, and they tie him|||他们去了阿塞拜疆。所以他到处出击。我的意思是，他非常热衷于往别人脸上踢沙子。对。而他往其脸上踢沙子的人群之一，是一个被称为德列夫利安人（Drevlians）的斯拉夫部族，他们俘虏了他。他们拉弯两棵白桦树，把他绑在——
to the ends of these two trees, and then they let the two birch trees go, so he goes, and he gets split in two, and that's the end of him. However, this is not a sensible thing to have done. Now, coming coming sent dominic it's not true that's dominic now center stage comes possibly the most interesting of all the rulers of kiev
to the ends of these two trees, and then they let the two birch trees go, so he goes, and he gets split in two, and that's the end of him. However, this is not a sensible thing to have done. Now, coming coming sent dominic it's not true that's dominic now center stage comes possibly the most interesting of all the rulers of kiev|||这两棵树的顶端，然后松开两棵白桦树，于是他整个人被撕成了两半，他的生命就此终结。然而，这么做可真不明智。现在，等等，圣多米尼克，这不是真的，那是多米尼克——现在，闪亮登场的是基辅所有统治者中最有趣的一位，
who is um the the wife of igor and the mother of sviatslav as he'll become. He will become this ruler. But she is ruling as regent. Olga, Helga. Yeah. You've got a bit of a torn dress for Olga, I think. I really have. I really have. She's kind of the Athelflad of the East. But she's much more...
who is um the the wife of igor and the mother of sviatslav as he'll become. He will become this ruler. But she is ruling as regent. Olga, Helga. Yeah. You've got a bit of a torn dress for Olga, I think. I really have. I really have. She's kind of the Athelflad of the East. But she's much more...|||也就是……伊戈尔的妻子、日后将成为统治者的斯维亚托斯拉夫的母亲。她以摄政身份统治。奥尔加（Olga），海尔加（Helga）。对。我觉得你给奥尔加准备的裙子有点破了。我真的有。我真的有。她有点像是东方的埃塞尔弗莱德（Athelflad，威塞克斯女杰）。但她要凶悍得多……
She's very robust in her approach to the Drevlians. So they're basically... They're Slavs, aren't they? They're the tree people because Derevo is tree in Russian. So presumably that's where the story of the birch trees. But also apparently the chronicler was ripping off… Theseus. Yeah, Diodorus or some Greek chronicler.
She's very robust in her approach to the Drevlians. So they're basically... They're Slavs, aren't they? They're the tree people because Derevo is tree in Russian. So presumably that's where the story of the birch trees. But also apparently the chronicler was ripping off… Theseus. Yeah, Diodorus or some Greek chronicler.|||她对待德列夫利安人的手段非常强硬。所以他们基本上……他们是斯拉夫人，对吧？他们是“树人”，因为在俄语中 Derevo 就是树的意思。所以大概这就是白桦树故事的来源。但显然，修史者也是在抄袭……忒修斯（Theseus）。对，狄奥多罗斯（Diodorus）或其他某个希腊史学家。
Yeah, it is. Yeah. But who cares? So like a lot of these stories stories like basically everything in this podcast possibly didn't happen so so so the drevlians are obviously a bit nervous whether um you know olga is going to be you know what's her reaction going to be so they send um an embassy to her and uh she puts them on a ship and buries them alive.
Yeah, it is. Yeah. But who cares? So like a lot of these stories stories like basically everything in this podcast possibly didn't happen so so so the drevlians are obviously a bit nervous whether um you know olga is going to be you know what's her reaction going to be so they send um an embassy to her and  she puts them on a ship and buries them alive.|||是的，确实如此。但谁在乎呢？所以就像许多这类故事一样——基本上这期播客里的所有事情可能都没有发生过——所以德列夫利安人显然有点紧张，不知道奥尔加会有什么反应。于是他们向她派出了使团，而她把他们装上一艘船，然后活埋了。
Yeah. Well, they've, you know what? They send the embassy saying, would you like to marry our leader, Prince Mal? Which is an extraordinary thing to do, the way they've treated
Yeah. Well, they've, you know what? They send the embassy saying, would you like to marry our leader, Prince Mal? Which is an extraordinary thing to do, the way they've treated|||对。嗯，你知道吗？他们派出的使团说：“你愿意嫁给我们的首领马尔亲王（Prince Mal）吗？”考虑到他们之前对待
her previous husband. Yeah, she throws, she buries them alive, doesn't she? On a ship. So a bit like the, we had Ibn Fadlan's account of the uh
her previous husband. Yeah, she throws, she buries them alive, doesn't she? On a ship. So a bit like the, we had Ibn Fadlan's account of the  the ship burial yeah she seems to have done that but they were alive um and i think she kind of taunts them as the soil is being flooded then that's just the first of because she yes she is she has three revenges doesn't she so another they then send another embassy because the first embassy hasn't returned|||她前夫的方式，这真是一件不可思议的事。对，她把他们活埋了，不是吗？在一艘船上。这有点像伊本·法德兰（Ibn Fadlan）对船葬的记述——对，她似乎就是这么做的，只不过他们当时还活着。我想当泥土填满舱底时，她还嘲讽了他们一番。但这只是开始，因为她确实进行了三次复仇，不是吗？所以随后他们又派了另一个使团，因为第一批使团没有回来。
the ship burial yeah she seems to have done that but they were alive um and i think she kind of taunts them as the soil is being flooded then that's just the first of because she yes she is she has three revenges doesn't she so another they then send another embassy because the first embassy hasn't returned yeah i'm so stupid what happened to those guys we'll send another one so so olga burns them alive that's right in the bathhouse she says go and have a wash yeah so obviously their standards of hygiene have improved by this point yeah clearly um and then she goes and besieges the city where eagle was killed and the story is is that she besieges them for a year and finally she
i'm so stupid what happened to those guys we'll send another one so so olga burns them alive that's right in the bathhouse she says go and have a wash yeah so obviously their standards of hygiene have improved by this point yeah clearly um and then she goes and besieges the city where eagle was killed and the story is is that she besieges them for a year and finally she|||“我们太蠢了，那些家伙怎么回事？我们再派一个去。”于是奥尔加把他们活活烧死了——没错，在浴室里。她说：“去洗个澡吧。”对，显然到这个时候他们的卫生标准有所提高了，这很明显。然后她去围城——伊戈尔被杀的那座城市。故事记载她围城一年，最后她
she accepts that she's not going to capture it. So she negotiates a treaty with them and demands a kind of, you know, a very small tribute just as a kind of sign of their submission. And she demands three sparrows and Dominic, three pigeons. And you've been mocking the idea that we're going to be doing a podcast on pigeons. But this is a kind of interesting example of how pigeons have played an important role in world history. I think you're underestimating the number of sparrows she asks for.
she accepts that she's not going to capture it. So she negotiates a treaty with them and demands a kind of, you know, a very small tribute just as a kind of sign of their submission. And she demands three sparrows and Dominic, three pigeons. And you've been mocking the idea that we're going to be doing a podcast on pigeons. But this is a kind of interesting example of how pigeons have played an important role in world history. I think you're underestimating the number of sparrows she asks for.|||接受了自己无法攻陷这座城市的事实。于是她与他们谈判达成一项条约，要求他们缴纳某种非常轻微的贡赋，作为臣服的象征。她要求每户交出三只麻雀和——多米尼克——三只鸽子。你之前一直在嘲笑我们将要做一期关于鸽子的播客的想法，但这却是一个有趣的例子，说明了鸽子如何在世界历史中扮演了重要角色。我觉得你低估了她要求的麻雀数量。
I think she asks for three sparrows from each household. Yeah, so each household have to give her a tribute. Not from the city, generally. No, no, yes. So each household has to give a tribute of three sparrows and three pigeons. And they do this and she then sets them on fire. They dive bomb the city.
I think she asks for three sparrows from each household. Yeah, so each household have to give her a tribute. Not from the city, generally. No, no, yes. So each household has to give a tribute of three sparrows and three pigeons. And they do this and she then sets them on fire. They dive bomb the city.|||我认为她要求每户人家提供三只麻雀。对，所以每户人家都必须向她进贡。不是从全城总量中出，而是每户。不，不，是的。所以每户人家必须进贡三只麻雀和三只鸽子。他们照做了，然后她把它们点燃。它们俯冲轰炸这座城市。
It bursts into flames. She bursts in and kills everybody. It's a great story. Do you think that happened, Dom? I mean, do you think that's a plausible? Well, there's a story that this happened during the war of Simon de Montfort against Henry III. The whole sparrow carry on again. It was a cock.
It bursts into flames. She bursts in and kills everybody. It's great story. Do you think that happened, Dom? I mean, do you think that's a plausible? Well, there's a story that this happened during the war of Simon de Montfort against Henry III. The whole sparrow carry on again. It was a cock.|||城市陷入火海。她冲进去杀光了所有人。这是一个精彩的故事。你觉得这真的发生过吗，汤姆？我的意思是，你觉得这合理吗？嗯，有传言说这发生在西蒙·德·孟福尔（Simon de Montfort）对抗亨利三世的战争期间。又是一整套麻雀的把戏。那是只公鸡。
Right. That they set fire to London. I think. With a burning cock. I think, obviously, this is all from the Russian Primary Chronicle, isn't it? Which I think is so clearly based on previous models. But I think it's a good story. So let's not question it.
Right. That they set fire to London. I think. With a burning cock. I think, obviously, this is all from the Russian Primary Chronicle, isn't it? Which I think is so clearly based on previous models. But I think it's a good story. So let's not question it.|||对。他们放火烧了伦敦。我想是的。用一只燃烧的公鸡。我认为，很显然，这都出自《俄罗斯初年纪事》，对吧？这显然是以先前的模式为基础编写的。但我认为这是一个好故事，所以我们别去质疑它了。
Let's assume it definitely happened. Okay. So Olga, robust in her approach to the murderers of her husband. But also a saint. A saint. Yes. So she, and it's, again, a sign of the growing influence of Byzantine culture and civilization, that she converts to Christianity and gets the baptismal name of Helena,
Let's assume it definitely happened. Okay. So Olga, robust in her approach to the murderers of her husband. But also a saint. A saint. Yes. So she, and it's, again, a sign of the growing influence of Byzantine culture and civilization, that she converts to Christianity and gets the baptismal name of Helena,|||我们就假设它绝对发生过吧。好吧。所以，奥尔加对待其丈夫凶手的手段极其强硬。但她也是一位圣人。一位圣人。是的。所以她——这也是拜占庭文化和文明影响力日益增强的又一个迹象——她皈依了基督教，并获得了洗礼名海伦娜（Helena），
which was the name of the mother of Constantine, who'd founded Constantinople. And her son doesn't convert, but she's allowed to serve as a patron of Christianity in Kiev. So she goes to Constantinople, does she, to talk to Constantine VII, the guy who wrote the manual, Porphyrogenitus. And there's some talk of them marrying but
which was the name of the mother of Constantine, who'd founded Constantinople. And her son doesn't convert, but she's allowed to serve as a patron of Christianity in Kiev. So she goes to Constantinople, does she, to talk to Constantine VII, the guy who wrote the manual, Porphyrogenitus. And there's some talk of them marrying but|||也就是建立君士坦丁堡的君士坦丁之母的名字。她的儿子没有皈依，但她被允许担任基辅基督教的赞助人。所以她去了君士坦丁堡，是吧？去拜访君士坦丁七世——那个写了《帝国行政论》（Porphyrogenitus）手册的家伙。关于他们结婚有一些传言，但
and they don't marry but she converts and she comes back with a load of vases it said in the chronicle which is nice yeah um but yeah but it's interesting because and this is one of those things that kind of makes a mockery of our attempts to fix labels on on these people because she is as you say a christian but her son sviatoslav he is still a rampaging pagan a pagan she has a scandinavian name helga he has a slavic name um but there's no sense that this is a kind of contradiction or that this is some problem that needs to be resolved it's just you know the the sort of the flux and a mess of how things are yep and and he um he like like his dad is a great conqueror so he knocks out the khazars well he's one of the first he's the first of these people we have a physical description of a genuine physical
and they don't marry but she converts and she comes back with a load of vases it said in the chronicle which is nice yeah um but but it's interesting because and this is one of those things that kind of makes a mockery of our attempts to fix labels on on these people because she is as you say a christian but her son sviatoslav he is still a rampaging pagan a pagan she has a scandinavian name helga he has a slavic name um but there's no sense that this is a kind of contradiction or that this is some problem that needs to be resolved it's just you know the the sort of the flux and a mess of how things are yep and and he um he like like his dad is a great conqueror so he knocks out the khazars well he's one of the first he's the first of these people we have a physical description of a genuine physical|||他们没有结婚，但她皈依了，纪事中说她带回来一大堆花瓶，挺不错的。对，嗯……但很有趣的是——这也是那些让我们试图给这些人贴标签的努力沦为笑柄的事情之一——正如你所说，她是一个基督徒，但她的儿子斯维亚托斯拉夫仍然是一个横行霸道的异教徒。一个异教徒。她有一个斯堪的纳维亚名字海尔加，他有一个斯拉夫名字。但这完全不被认为是一种矛盾，也不是什么需要解决的问题，它只是……你知道的，事物原本那种变幻莫测、一团乱麻的状态。对，而且他……他和他的父亲一样是一位伟大的征服者，所以他击溃了可萨人（Khazars）。嗯，他是第一批人中……我们拥有真实体貌描述的第一批人，拥有真实的体貌
description made by um who is it by one of the byzantines uh leo the deacon he says he's a moderate height he's got a snub nose uh he's got a sort of bushy mustache and a shaved head but a lock of hair that hangs down on one side that's right yes kind of hanging down the side isn't it he had a rather angry and savage appearance. You're telling me. He's got a gold earring with two pearls and a red gemstone. His clothing was white, no different from that of his companions, except in cleanliness. So he's well turned out, despite his savage appearance.
description made by um who is it by one of the byzantines  leo the deacon he says he's a moderate height he's got a snub nose  he's got a sort of bushy mustache and a shaved head but a lock of hair that hangs down on one side that's right yes kind of hanging down the side isn't it he had a rather angry and savage appearance. You're telling me. He's got a gold earring with two pearls and a red gemstone. His clothing was white, no different from that of his companions, except in cleanliness. So he's well turned out, despite his savage appearance.|||描述是由……是谁做的？拜占庭人之一，执事利奥（Leo the Deacon）。他说他中等身材，有一个塌鼻子，留着浓密的胡须，剃光了头，但有一绺头发垂在脑袋一侧。对，是的，垂在脑侧，对吧？他有着相当愤怒和野蛮的外表。不用你说。他戴着一个镶有两颗珍珠和一颗红宝石的金耳环。他的衣服是白色的，除了更干净一些外，和他的同伴没什么两样。所以尽管他外表野蛮，但他打扮得挺利落。
And yeah, sorry, Tom, I interrupted you. He wipes the floor with the Khazars, doesn't he? Yes, he does. And is he the father of, well, Vladimir is is russian vladimir i gather if you're ukrainian he is yeah um but but again a name that people think possibly has sort of norse germanic roots and it could have been valde valdemar um some kind of norse name but yeah he so he attacks the bulgars. He attacks the Khazars. I mean, you're saying that Igor
And yeah, sorry, Tom, I interrupted you. He wipes the floor with the Khazars, doesn't he? Yes, he does. And is he the father of, well, Vladimir is is russian vladimir i gather if you're ukrainian he is yeah um but but again a name that people think possibly has sort of norse germanic roots and it could have been valde valdemar um some kind of norse name but yeah he so he attacks the bulgars. He attacks the Khazars. I mean, you're saying that Igor|||对，抱歉，汤姆，我打断你了。他把可萨人打得落花流水，对吧？是的，他确实做到了。他是不是……弗拉基米尔（Vladimir）在俄罗斯叫弗拉基米尔，据我所知，如果你是乌克兰人，他就是……对，嗯……但这又是一个人们认为可能具有诺斯-日耳曼语根源的名字，它可能是瓦尔德、瓦尔德马（Valdemar）——某种诺斯语名字。但无论如何，他攻击了保加尔人。他攻击了可萨人。我的意思是，你刚才说伊戈尔
is expansionist. Sviatoslav is very expansionist. He fights absolutely. Vladimir. Yeah. No, Sviatoslav. Oh,
is expansionist. Sviatoslav is very expansionist. He fights absolutely. Vladimir. Yeah. No, Sviatoslav. Oh,|||充满扩张欲。斯维亚托斯拉夫也非常具有扩张欲。他绝对一直在打仗。弗拉基米尔。对。不，是斯维亚托斯拉夫。哦，
yes, yes. He's very expansionist, but he has an interesting death too, Tom. None of them die safely quietly in their bed. Do you know what happens to him?
yes, yes. He's very expansionist, but he has an interesting death too, Tom. None of them die safely quietly in their bed. Do you know what happens to him?|||对，对。他非常具有扩张欲，但他的死也很有趣，汤姆。他们当中没有人能安稳平静地死在自己的床上。你知道他发生了什么事吗？
Tell me. He has gone and attacked Constantinople again. As you do. As you do. I mean, presumably, I think they're attacking Constantinople again. As you do. As you do. I mean, presumably, I think they're attacking Constantinople to get better trade. They're like Lord Frost, who's obviously listening to the show
Tell me. He has gone and attacked Constantinople again. As you do. As you do. I mean, presumably, I think they're attacking Constantinople again. As you do. As you do. I mean, presumably, I think they're attacking Constantinople to get better trade. They're like Lord Frost, who's obviously listening to the show|||告诉我。他又去攻击君士坦丁堡了。不愧是他。常规操作。我的意思是，我想他们再次攻击君士坦丁堡。常规操作。常规操作。我的意思是，我想他们攻击君士坦丁堡是为了获得更好的贸易。他们就像弗罗斯特勋爵（Lord Frost），他显然在收听这个节目，
and presumably listening to the show an awful lot now that he's left his Brexit. Got more time. I'm disappointed he hasn't been sending in more of those excellent Danish-themed questions. But yeah, they're presumably doing it to get tribute and to get you know money and better trade negotiations and stuff but he's gone and attacked the constantinople it didn't really work out he comes back and he ends up being ambushed
and presumably listening to the show an awful lot now that he's left his Brexit. Got more time. I'm disappointed he hasn't been sending in more of those excellent Danish-themed questions. But yeah, they're presumably doing it to get tribute and to get you know money and better trade negotiations and stuff but he's gone and attacked the constantinople it didn't really work out he comes back and he ends up being ambushed|||而且鉴于他现在已经退出了脱欧事务，有了更多空闲时间，他大概把这个节目听了无数遍。我很失望他没有发来更多那些精彩的丹麦主题问题。但话说回来，他们这么做大概是为了获取贡赋、金钱和更好的贸易谈判之类的东西。但他去攻击了君士坦丁堡，结果并不太顺利，他在返回时遭到伏击——
at the rapids on the river dnieper by our old friends the Pechenegs. And do you know what they do to him? No, tell me. They cut his head off, they plate it with gold, and they use it as a drinking vessel. That's so predictable. That's kind of very, it's like, they're always doing that.
at the rapids on the river dnieper by our old friends the Pechenegs. And do you know what they do to him? No, tell me. They cut his head off, they plate it with gold, and they use it as a drinking vessel. That's so predictable. That's kind of very, it's like, they're always doing that.|||在第聂伯河的激流处，被我们的老朋友佩切涅格人（Pechenegs）伏击了。你知道他们对他是怎么做的吗？不知道，快告诉我。他们砍下他的头，用黄金包起来，把它当作饮酒的容器。这太意料之中了。这有点像……他们总是这么干。
They're always doing that. Vulcan formulaic behaviour. I think tying to a tree and, you know and ripping them in half is much more creative. Okay, fair enough. Even if it didn't happen. Yeah, even if it didn't happen. So anyway, he has multiple sons. They all fight each other. And the winner is…
Always doing that. Vulcan formulaic behaviour. I think tying to a tree and, you know and ripping them in half is much more creative. Okay, fair enough. Even if it didn't happen. Yeah, even if it didn't happen. So anyway, he has multiple sons. They all fight each other. And the winner is…|||总是这样。老套的程式化行为。我觉得把人绑在树上然后撕成两半更有创意。好吧，有道理。哪怕这事儿没发生过。对，哪怕没发生过。总之，他有几个儿子。他们互相残杀。赢家是……
Volodymyr. Yeah. Volodymyr. Well, it's interesting, actually, Tom, because almost every book on this calls him Vladimir, which is Russian. But I've been told off by Ukrainians for calling him Vladimir. Agreed. So if you look at Sergei Plokhy's book on the history of Ukraine, he calls him Volodymyr. And it's a bit like we've talked about Kiev, you know, and in our minds, no doubt, because we're born in the 70s.
Volodymyr. Yeah. Volodymyr. Well, it's interesting, actually, Tom, because almost every book on this calls him Vladimir, which is Russian. But I been told off by Ukrainians for calling him Vladimir. Agreed. So if you look at Sergei Plokhy's book on the history of Ukraine, he calls him Volodymyr. And it's a bit like we've talked about Kiev, you know, and in our minds, no doubt, because we're born in the 70s.|||弗沃迪米尔（Volodymyr）。对。弗沃迪米尔。嗯，这其实很有趣，汤姆，因为几乎所有关于这方面的书都叫他弗拉基米尔（Vladimir），这是俄语名。但我因为叫他弗拉基米尔而被乌克兰人训斥过。同意。所以如果你看谢尔希·普洛希（Serhii Plokhy）写的关于乌克兰历史的书，他称他为弗沃迪米尔。这有点像我们之前谈论基辅（Kiev），你知道的，在我们脑海里，毫无疑问，因为我们出生在70年代，
That word is spelt K-I-E-v not k-y-i-v so at this point we're getting more and more into the kind of territory where everything is contested between russian and ukrainian but what isn't contested is the absolute key significance of his reign because it's in his reign yeah that the ukrain, the Rus, become Christian. You call them Ukrainians? Well, yeah, the Rus. Please direct all your complaints to Tom Holland, not to me. The Rus, the Russians, the Ukrainians, whatever.
That word is spelt K-I-E-v not k-y-i-v so at this point we're getting more and more into the kind of territory where everything is contested between russian and ukrainian but what isn't contested is the absolute key significance of his reign because it's in his reign yeah that the ukrain, the Rus, become Christian. You call them Ukrainians? Well, yeah, the Rus. Please direct all your complaints to Tom Holland, not to me. The Rus, the Russians, the Ukrainians, whatever.|||那个词拼作 K-I-E-V，而不是 K-Y-I-V。所以在这一点上，我们越来越进入那种俄罗斯和乌克兰之间一切都存在争议的领域。但没有争议的是他统治的绝对核心意义，因为正是在他的统治时期——对——乌克兰人……罗斯人皈依了基督教。你叫他们乌克兰人？好吧，对，罗斯人。请把所有的投诉直接发给汤姆·霍兰，不要发给我。罗斯人、俄罗斯人、乌克兰人，随便啦。
So, Tom, tell us, because his conversion to Christianity is a great tale in itself, isn't it? Well, we've been talking about how so much of this material has a kind of folkloric dimension to it yeah and in the previous episode we talked about the khazars about how um you know they they can't decide whether to become christian or jewish or muslim and there's a very similar story told about blodimir he's in a world surrounded by worshippers of a single god, which should he convert to? And so he sends emissaries to the Muslim world, to the caliphate, and they report back and say, well, you'd have to give up drink.
So, Tom, tell us, because his conversion to Christianity is a great tale in itself, isn't it? Well, we've been talking about how so much of this material has a kind of folkloric dimension to it yeah and in the previous episode we talked about the khazars about how um you know they they can't decide whether to become christian or jewish or muslim and there's a very similar story told about blodimir he's in a world surrounded by worshippers of a single god, which should he convert to? And so he sends emissaries to the Muslim world, to the caliphate, and they report back and say, well, you'd have to give up drink.|||所以，汤姆，给我们讲讲吧，因为他皈依基督教本身就是一个绝佳的故事，对吧？嗯，我们一直在谈论这些材料中有多少具有某种民间传说的维度。是的，在上一集里我们谈到了可萨人，谈到他们……你知道的，他们无法决定是皈依基督教、犹太教还是伊斯兰教。关于弗沃迪米尔也有一个非常类似的故事：他身处一个被单一神明崇拜者包围的世界，他应该皈依哪一个？于是他向穆斯林世界、向哈里发国派遣了特使，他们回报说：嗯，你得戒酒。
So that's an absolute no-no. And he sends them to the lands of the Franks, and they report back and say, yeah, it's all right, but cathedrals aren't great. And then he sends them to Constantinople and they go to Hagia Sophia, the great cathedral. And they come back and they report in odd terms. We knew not whether we were in heaven or on earth for on earth,
So that's an absolute no-no. And he sends them to the lands of the Franks, and they report back and say, yeah, it's all right, but cathedrals aren't great. And then he sends them to Constantinople and they go to Hagia Sophia, the great cathedral. And they come back and they report in odd terms. We knew not whether we were in heaven or on earth for on earth,|||所以这是绝对不行的。然后他把他们派往法兰克的土地，他们回报说：嗯，还行，但大教堂不怎么样。接着他把他们派往君士坦丁堡，他们去了圣索菲亚大教堂这座宏伟的大教堂。他们回来后，用奇怪的辞藻汇报说：我们不知道自己是在天堂还是在人间，因为在人间，
there is no such splendor or such beauty. We only know that God dwells there among men. We cannot forget that beauty. And so this persuades Vladimir that he should go with Orthodox Christianity, the Christianity of Constantinople. Now, that story is obviously... Completely true. Not true.
there is no such splendor or such beauty. We only know that God dwells there among men. We cannot forget that beauty. And so this persuades Vladimir that he should go with Orthodox Christianity, the Christianity of Constantinople. Now, that story is obviously... Completely true. Not true.|||绝无如此的辉煌与美丽。我们只知道上帝就居住在那里的世人中间。我们无法忘记那种美。这说服了弗沃迪米尔，让他决定选择正教会基督教——君士坦丁堡的基督教。现在，这个故事显然是……完全真实的。假的。
Oh, Tom, don't say that. Because those are the most famous foundational lines. I know. At the centre of kind of Russian, Belarusian, Ukrainian... But there are two obvious reasons why they're not true. Go on. The first is that they're very familiar with Constantinople. Yeah, because they've been...
哦，汤姆，别这么说。因为那些是最著名、最基础的台词。我知道。在某种程度上，它们是俄罗斯、白俄罗斯、乌克兰的核心……但有两个显而易见的原因表明它们并不真实。请继续。首先，他们对君士坦丁堡非常熟悉。是的，因为他们一直……
They don't need to send emissaries out to report back on what Hagia Sophia is like. They've been there. They know that. And the other is that this is very geopolitically determined of course they're choosing a super bow right they're choosing a super power yeah but tom i'm gutted that you missed out um that they also went to visit the bulgars on the vulgar and you know what they said when they came back from the vulgar when we journeyed among the
他们不需要派使者去汇报圣索菲亚大教堂是什么样子的。他们去过那里。他们对此很清楚。另一个原因是，这具有很强的地缘政治决定性，他们当然会选择超级大国，对吧？他们会选择一个超级大国，是的。但汤姆，我很难过，你漏掉了……他们还去拜访了伏尔加河畔的保加利亚人，你知道他们从伏尔加河回来后是怎么说的吗？当我们游历于
bulgars we beheld how they worship in their temple called a mosque while they stand on girt the bulgar bow sits down looks hither and thither like one possessed and there is no happiness among them but instead only only sorrow and a dreadful stench that's not you wouldn't choose that religion would you no you wouldn't you wouldn't go for that one not the stench um so uh apologies to any uh well bulgarians and bulgarians um but you get you get you know i mean that great incense in i guess fear no stench there very beautiful so he's obviously choosing it as power politics isn't he um well and the byzantines are as well because they offer vladimir something that no barbarian leader has
保加利亚人中时，我们看到他们在被称为清真寺的庙宇中如何崇拜，当他们站立束腰时，保加利亚的鞠躬者坐下来，东张西望，就像着了魔一样，那里没有快乐，只有悲伤和难闻的恶臭。那可不行，你不会选择那种宗教，对吧？不，你不会的，你不会选那个，不是因为恶臭。所以，嗯，向任何……嗯，保加利亚人道歉，但你懂的，我是说，在恐惧中那美妙的香气，我想那里没有恶臭，非常美丽。所以他显然是出于权力和政治来选择它的，不是吗？嗯，拜占庭人也是如此，因为他们为弗拉基米尔提供了一项任何蛮族首领都
ever been offered before by Byzantine emperor. And that is marriage into the imperial family in the form of the emperor's Basil II's sister, Anna. Yeah, she's not happy, is she? She's not happy at all. She apparently is very cross about it. And there's some sort of breakdown in negotiations because he has to actually attack the Crimea. Well, that's where it all happens, isn't it? Yeah.
从未从拜占庭皇帝那里获得过的东西。那就是与皇室联姻，对象是皇帝巴西尔二世的妹妹安娜。是的，她很不高兴，对吧？她一点也不高兴。据说她对此非常生气。谈判似乎出了一些故障，因为他实际上不得不进攻克里米亚。嗯，那就是一切发生的地方，对吧？是的。
I mean, so the Crimea, which is obviously very, you know, it's in the crosshairs of current politics. The Crimea matters to both Ukrainians and Russians today because it's where Vladimir is bapt baptized and then marries Anna. Yeah. And he has a weird thing where he has at the baptism, he has all the old idols cast down and he ties, there's an idol of somebody called Peron who was made of wood
我的意思是，克里米亚显然非常……你知道的，它正处于当前政治的焦点风口浪尖。克里米亚对今天的乌克兰人和俄罗斯人来说都很重要，因为弗拉基米尔就是在那儿受洗并娶了安娜。是的。他有一件奇怪的事，就是在受洗时，他让人把所有旧偶像都推倒，然后把一个叫佩龙的木制偶像绑在
and had a golden moustache. And he's tied to a horse's tail and dragged down a hill. And then Philodemir gets 12 men to beat him with cudgels as a sort of sign, you know, I'm rejecting the old gods and embracing a new one. But it's also, I mean, obviously it's a two-way process, isn't it? Because as you said, the Varangian guard, it's not Philodemir said the the varangian guard it's it's not vladimir who sends the varangian the big the big contingent that become the varangian guard to constantinople because because that's part of the treaty with uh with basil yeah yeah basil
马尾巴上，拖下一座山。然后弗拉基米尔让12个人用大棒殴打他，以此作为一种标志，你知道的，我拒绝旧神，拥抱新神。但这当然也是一个双向的过程，不是吗？因为正如你所说，瓦兰吉亚卫队，并不是弗拉基米尔说……瓦兰吉亚卫队，不是弗拉基米尔把庞大的瓦兰吉亚卫队派往君士坦丁堡，因为那是与巴西尔条约的一部分……是的，是的，巴西尔……
what you would assume wouldn't you that they must have had varangian mercenaries in their army before they had the official guard. Harold Hardrada ends up being the commander. So Harold Hardrada is, I mean, in a way, he's the kind of the end of the story, the end point of the story, isn't he? He is. We'll take a quick break.
你会这么认为，对吧？在拥有官方卫队之前，他们的军队里一定有瓦兰吉亚雇佣兵。哈拉尔·哈德拉达最终成为了指挥官。所以哈拉尔·哈德拉达，从某种意义上说，他是这个故事的结局，故事的终点，对吗？他是。我们稍作休息。
When we come back, we'll talk Harold Hardrada and really the end of the Viking Age. Okay. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews,
回来后，我们将讨论哈拉尔·哈德拉达以及维京时代的真正终点。好的。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐滑铁卢》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论的固定栏目，
splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com.
还有一点八卦八卦，在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告节目、独家单集以及优先购买现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。
That's therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are reaching the end of the Viking Age, which we've told entirely through a focus on the Vikings in the East. And the last and most famous Viking character, I think, certainly in England, to have been Eastward bound is Harold Hardrada, who we know as the man who lost the Battle of Stamford Bridge, but had the most extraordinary life and career before that, didn't he, Tom?
那是 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的其余部分》。我们正在接近维京时代的尾声，我们完全通过聚焦东方的维京人来讲述这段历史。我认为，最后也是最著名的维京人物，尤其是在英国，曾向东进发的就是哈拉尔·哈德拉达。我们知道他是斯坦福桥战役的失败者，但在那之前，他有着极其不平凡的生活和职业生涯，不是吗，汤姆？
He really did. And we've been focusing on the first part of this episode on the princes part of this episode on the uh the princes of kiev um this kind of emergent russ state but all along up in scandinavia you've still got kind of viking adventurers who are treating these eastern lands as places that you can kind of retreat to if you need to yeah also places to make money basically and bring back tons of silver so harold um harold sigurdsson he's the the brother of of um olaf sigurdsson olaf the stout who will become uh saint olaf the patron saint of norway um and he he's he's briefly been king he messes up he gets killed uh and supposedly martyred the battle called stickler stad um which harold is at because harold is a teenager i think at that battle his knee is about 15 or so
确实如此。在本集的上半部分，我们一直聚焦于基辅诸侯的部分，这种新兴的罗斯国家，但在斯堪的纳维亚半岛的一直以来，你仍然有一些维京冒险家，他们把这些东方土地当作你可以在需要时退守的地方，是的，也是基本上赚钱并带回大量白银的地方。所以哈拉尔……哈拉尔·西居尔松，他是……奥拉夫·西居尔松的兄弟，刚毅者奥拉夫，他后来成为挪威的守护圣人圣奥拉夫……他曾短暂做过国王，但他搞砸了，被杀了，据称在斯蒂克尔斯塔德的战役中殉道，哈拉尔当时也在场，因为哈拉尔在那个战役中还是个十几岁的少年，我想他当时大概15岁左右，
yeah and he has to go into exile and and that his and he goes to novgorod and this is tom actually for those people who are who have found this all a bit sci-fi because it's lots of weird names and stuff um their big antagonist is Knute famous for wave to attempting or not attempting to turn back waves again something that didn't happen um end of the show an early faller in the rest is history world cup of kings kings but I think a very impressive king I mean a very formidable king indeed so king of a North Sea empire um he's basically taken over England after the end of Ethelred the Unready. He's married to Emma from Normandy.
是的，他不得不流亡，他的……他去了诺夫哥罗德。汤姆，对于那些觉得这一切有点像科幻小说的人来说，因为这里有很多奇怪的名字等等，他们最大的对头是克努特，以试图或并未试图阻止海浪而闻名，这其实并没有发生……节目的最后，在历史世界杯的国王评选中表现不佳，但我认为他是一位非常令人印象深刻的国王，一个真正强大的国王。所以他是北海帝国的国王……在铁腕埃塞尔雷德统治结束后，他基本上接管了英国。他娶了来自诺曼底的艾玛。
So it all connects. Everything connects. So he's the great antagonist that basically, the young Harold Hardrider is terrified of Canute. He flees and he ends up- It is. I mean, it is a Western, isn't it? Yeah.
所以这一切都连系在一起。一切都连系在一起。所以他是主要的对手，基本上，年轻的哈拉尔·哈德拉达对克努特感到恐惧。他逃跑了，最终……确实如此。我的意思是，这就像是一部西部片，对吧？
Or a mafia story or a science fiction story. I mean, you can see how the patterns of these stories, why it's such a kind of great setting for an epic. It is. Absolutely. He's been run out of town by the local cattle rustler. Yeah. But as a boy, as a teenager, got you know such a stuff of a kind of
或者是一个黑帮故事，或是一部科幻小说。我的意思是，你可以看出这些故事的模式，为什么它会成为史诗的绝佳背景。确实如此。绝对是的。他被当地的牧牛贼赶出了小镇。是的。但作为一个男孩，一个十几岁的小伙子，拥有那种……
children's story he goes off down the river like so many people have for what what is it now 250 years yeah and he ends up in kiev where the successor to vladimir i think it is um yaroslav the wise also known as the lame is now um he can well, he could be wise and lame, couldn't he? Yeah, well, he's lame to begin with, and then he's so wise that he gets promoted. Right, that's good. So he's upwardly mobile. Yeah. He'd beaten off his brother.
儿童故事的素材，他顺流而下，就像许多人过去250年所做的那样，是的，他最终来到了基辅，弗拉基米尔的继承人，我想是……智慧的雅罗斯拉夫，也被称为跛子，现在是……他可以……嗯，他又聪明又跛，对吧？是的，好吧，他一开始是跛子，后来因为太聪明而得到了提拔。对，那挺好的。所以他在不断高升。是的。他击退了他的兄弟。
He's upwardly mobile, but not kind of mobile. They've had kind of an amazing war with his brother, fratricidal war, where they're fighting across ice-covered rivers and amazing. Yeah. The first great Northern War. That's very good. But Harold Hardrada wasn't in that war, was he? No.
他在不断晋升，但并非那种……他们和他的兄弟打了一场惊人的战争，一场兄弟相残的战争，他们在冰封的河面上战斗，太惊人了。是的。第一次伟大北方战争。这很棒。但哈拉尔·哈德拉达没有参加那场战争，对吧？没有。
So by this point, Yaroslav is the kind of the wise king. And Hardrada, who's not yet Hardrada, he's just Harold Sigurdsson. The young Harold. So he pitches up and he becomes basically an enforcer for Yaroslav, doesn't he? He serves in his guard or whatever. Why does he end up going further down towards Constantinople, Tom? Well, I think he is looking to get back to Norway. That's the ultimate aim.
所以到了这个时候，雅罗斯拉夫成了智者国王。而哈德拉达——还不是哈德拉达，他只是哈拉尔·西居尔松，年轻的哈拉尔。所以他赶到那里，基本上成了雅罗斯拉夫的打手，对吧？他在他的卫队或诸如此类的队伍中服役。为什么他最终会向南朝着君士坦丁堡进发呢，汤姆？嗯，我想他是想回到挪威。那是最终的目标。
And, you know,iev's all very well but the place where you're really going to make money is constantinople so he's going down there with the aim of in his cash in his cash because when he so he goes down there he he makes a tremendous success of it uh and the the right you know the epic story still isn't an epic telling his adventures uh he fights with dragons he marries princesses he goes to the holy land he conquers sicily he is but he genuinely does some of these things doesn't he really does go to yeah he goes to he goes to sicily with the byzantine i'm something here that says he's a marine. He's a marine in the Byzantine fleet with a man called Georgios Maniarches. Do you know him? Is he a eunuch?
而且，你知道的，基辅固然不错，但真正能赚大钱的地方是君士坦丁堡，所以他去那里是为了赚取现金，因为当他去到那里时，他取得了巨大的成功，而且……史诗般的故事仍然在继续，讲述他的冒险经历——他与龙搏斗，娶公主，去圣地，征服西西里，他真的做了其中一些事情，不是吗？他真的去了……是的，他带着拜占庭军队去了西西里。我这里有些资料说他是海军陆战队员。他是拜占庭舰队的一名海军陆战队员，和一个叫乔治斯·马尼亚奇斯的人在一起。你认识他吗？他是个太监吗？
No, he's the brother of a eunuch, isn't he, or something like that? Of course. I knew everybody was the brother of a eunuch. And Harold plays a great trick on Maniarches when they're in Sicily. Do you know about this trick? Remind me. It's an excellent trick. So they're discussing about who's going to get the best campsite for them
不，他是某个太监的兄弟，对吧，诸如此类？当然。我早知道每个人都是某个太监的兄弟。当他们在西西里时，哈拉尔对马尼亚奇斯开了一个大玩笑。你知道这个玩笑吗？提醒我一下。这是一个极好的玩笑。所以他们正在讨论谁能为自己和军队的那部分人争取到最好的营地。
and their part of the army. And they decide to draw lots. And Maniarchies marks his lot with a sort of a mark on it, his thing, whatever they're using. And Harold says, well, can I have a look at your lot so that I can mark mine in a different way? And Maniaki says, oh, yeah, yeah, of course. So they then put the both in a bag, and another man takes the lot out,
他们决定抽签。马尼亚奇斯在他的签上做了一个记号，作为他的标志，无论他们用的是什么。哈拉尔说：“嗯，我能看看你的签吗，这样我可以用不同的方式做我的标记？”马尼亚奇斯说：“哦，行，行，当然可以。”于是他们把两支签都放进一个袋子里，另一个人把签抽出来，
and Harold takes it, and he throws it in the sea and he says that was my lot i've won you know i get the best place for my for the for the that was good fooling i haven't finished the story he says that was and maniaka says how do i know that was yours i mean there's no way i can know that was yours and how it says we'll have a look in the bag. And Maniakis looks in the bag and he takes out the lot and it's got his mark on it. He says, oh, it must've been yours.
哈拉尔拿到了，他把它扔进海里说：“那是我的签，我赢了，你知道的，我为我的……争取到了最好的地方。”这玩笑开得挺好，我还没讲完故事呢。他说：“那是……”马尼亚奇斯说：“我怎么知道那是你的？我的意思是，我根本无法知道那是你的。”哈拉尔说：“我们看看袋子。”马尼亚奇斯看了看袋子，拿出了那支签，上面有他的标记。他说：“哦，那一定是你的。”
But of course, Harold made the same mark on his lot as on Maniakis'. The lesson of that story is that Maniakis is an absolute idiot. I think it's a lesson that Harold's an absolute japester. Right. Great one for the prank. Anyway, I mean,
但当然，哈拉尔在自己的签上做了和马尼亚奇斯一样的记号。那个故事的教训是，马尼亚奇斯是个绝对的笨蛋。我认为教训是哈拉尔是个绝对的恶作剧者。没错。真是个恶作剧高手。总之，我的意思是，
you're portraying him as a sort of les dawson figure but actually it's dawson and he's a prankster isn't he i mean i don't know he's a joker no he's a great barrel yeah he's not a mother-in-law joke man no no he slapped you on the back but he so your your teeth go flying out he then gets drawn into he goes back to he goes all these campaigns goes to the holy land he goes to to, he does all these campaigns, goes to the Holy Land, he goes to Bulgaria, all sorts of campaigns. He's very, very highly rated by the Byzantines. They make him a spatharo candidatus. I'm very glad I read that out correctly.
你把他描绘成一个像莱斯·道森那样的人物，但实际上他就是道森，而且他是个恶作剧者，不是吗？我的意思是，我不知道，他是个滑稽人物？不，他是个大块头，是的。他可不是讲岳母笑话的人。不，不，他拍拍你的背，结果你的牙齿都飞出去了。然后他被卷入……他回去了，他参加了所有这些战役，去了圣地，去了……他参加了所有这些战役，去了圣地，去了保加利亚，各种各样的战役。他受到了拜占庭人的极高评价。他们封他为“宫廷侍卫候选人”（spatharo candidatus）。我很高兴我正确地读出了这个词。
He's a spatharo candidatus, which is a very high rank for a foreigner. And he's been given a pay rise and he's the commander of the palace guard and all this that and the other and then he gets drawn into the the power politics are you familiar with all these michaels it's very yes i mean it's almost impossible not to get drawn into it isn't it when you reach a certain level yeah well this is the thing so michael iv is the emperor i think well he's married to the Emperor Zoe, and they have all kinds of feuding. And at some point, basically, Harold is told by Zoe, get the guy who's been kicked out as emperor and gouge his eyes out, please. And he does.
他是“宫廷侍卫候选人”，对于一个外国人来说，这是非常高的军衔。他加薪了，成了宫廷卫队的指挥官等等诸如此类，然后他被卷入了权力政治之中……你熟悉所有这些叫“米凯尔”的人吗？是的，我的意思是，当你达到一定级别时，几乎不可能不被卷入其中，不是吗？是的，就是这样：米凯尔四世是皇帝，我想……嗯，他娶了皇帝佐伊，他们之间有各种各样的争斗。在某个时候，基本上，佐伊对哈拉尔说：“去把那个被赶下台的皇帝抓来，把他的眼睛挖出来，求你了。”他照做了。
He personally can't trust his men to do it. So he gouges them out. I mean, the sense you get of Harold is that he's very much the kind of guy who, you know, guy needs to have his eyes gouged out. He's going to do it. Yeah, he's hands on. And when an emperor dies, the tradition is that the Varangians get to strip the imperial palace of all his gold. So Harold does that. And Harold actually is there for so long long he gets to do that three times so he's by the time he heads back he's so rich he's incredibly rich the empress zoe who's in
他亲自去，因为他不相信自己的人能做好。所以他挖出了他们的眼睛。我的意思是，你对哈拉尔的感观是，他非常那种……“哦，这家伙的眼睛得被挖出来”——他就会去干。是的，他是亲力亲为的。当一个皇帝去世时，传统是瓦兰吉亚人可以剥夺帝国宫殿里所有的黄金。所以哈拉尔就这样做了。事实上，哈拉尔在那里待了足够长的时间，以至于他做了三次这样的事，所以当他启程返回时，他太富有了，简直富得流油。那个已经60多岁的佐伊皇后，
her 60s quite fancies marrying him yeah but she has a bad habit of murdering her husbands and gouging their eyes out yeah so harold is not keen on that and and at some point he's locked up in a um a dungeon with a dragon i I think. Yeah, he escapes. He escapes from Constantinople. I mean, as with so much of this. You know, how much of this is true? A little bit, I think, with him, because we've got Byzantine sources. The stuff in the sagas, obviously, clearly quite, you know,
挺想嫁给他的。是的，但她有一个坏习惯，就是谋杀丈夫并挖出他们的眼睛。是的，所以哈拉尔对这不感兴趣，而且在某个时候，他被关进了一个有龙的地牢里，我想是的。他逃跑了。他从君士坦丁堡逃了出来。我的意思是，就像这里的许多事情一样。这一切有多少是真的？我认为关于他，多多少少有一点，因为我们有拜占庭的文献来源。传奇故事中的内容，显然，很明显……
the same people who worked on the sagas worked on the TV series Vikings, basically. I mean, the two things that are clearly true is that he comes back from Constantinople with a formidable fighting record. Yeah. You know, he is the hard rider, the hard ruler. And also that he's unbelievably rich. Yeah. I'm conscious that we've told his story in a quite shambolic way. Yeah, we have.
编写传奇故事的那拨人基本上也参与了电视剧《维京传奇》的制作。我的意思是，有两件事是显而易见的：第一，他从君士坦丁堡回来时有着令人敬畏的战斗记录。是的。你知道，他是个“强硬的骑手”，一个强硬的统治者。第二，他富得难以置信。是的。我意识到我们以一种相当混乱的方式讲述了他的故事。是的，我们确实如此。
But I think he's not the subject of this podcast he's just but he's the last he's the last so we can be forgiven for that so we can talk we you know he he's he's got this money basically so that he can then get together a large army uh and go and get back the throne of norway which is what he does which is basically in the long run there's a lot of carry on with his brother is it magnus his half-brother they split the kingdom and magnus dies and harold becomes a very very fierce and ruthless king of norway hence the name hard rider hard ruler i mean the only thing about that is you know is that a career peak because would you rather be the captain of the guard in constantinople or the king of norway i'd rather be king of norway would you
但我认为他不是这个播客的主题，他只是……但他已经是最后一个了，所以我们可以被原谅。所以我们可以谈谈……你知道，他有了这笔钱，基本上是为了能够集结一支大军，去夺回挪威的王位，这正是他所做的。从长远来看，这基本上涉及到与他兄弟的许多纠葛，是马格努斯吗？他的同母异父兄弟，他们瓜分了王国，然后马格努斯死了，哈拉尔成为了一个非常凶猛、冷酷的挪威国王，因此有了“硬统治者”（Hardrada）这个名字，意为强硬的统治者。我的意思是，关于这一点唯一的疑问是，这算是一个职业巅峰吗？你是宁愿当君士坦丁堡的卫队队长，还是挪威国王？我宁愿当挪威国王。你会吗？
yeah because in constantinople you're surrounded by predatory empresses and eunuchs eunuchs and yeah but i think in constant the weather is better the food's a hell of a lot better there's more money everything is nicer no but you're but you're not the whole thing is to have your own your own land yeah I suppose it is you're right but if you have you have a you have a slave's attitude to life whereas if you're you know
是的，因为在君士坦丁堡，你周围都是掠夺成性的皇后和太监，还有……是的，但我认为在君士坦丁堡天气更好，食物好得多，钱更多，一切都更美好。不，但是你……但这不是全部，关键是要有你自己的土地。是的，我想是的，你是对的。但如果你有……你有一种奴隶般的生活态度，而如果你是……
who are you French Rollerquizing there Harold Hardrada okay I have the spirit of a Viking right I think Harold
你在模仿哪个法国角色？哈拉尔·哈德拉达？好吧，我有维京人的精神。我想哈拉尔……
you have the spirit of a eunuch thanks I'll remember that I think Harold Hardrada I think the spirit of a Viking. Right. I think Harold, you should. You have the spirit of a eunuch. Thanks. I'll remember that. I think Harold Hardrada. I think the truth hurts. I think Harold Hardrada. Absolutely, you've betrayed yourself.
你有太监的精神。谢谢，我会记住这一点的。我想哈拉尔·哈德拉达……我认为真相往往很伤人。我想哈拉尔·哈德拉达……绝对的，你已经暴露了你自己。
Well, let's see what happens to Harold Hardrada, Tom. Well, he dies. But, you know, hero's death. So that's the perfect thing, isn't it? That Harold Hardrada dies 1066, the year that basically, you know, traditionally it's, it's the kind of the quietest of the Viking age. And he is,
好吧，让我们看看哈拉尔·哈德拉达的结局如何，汤姆。好吧，他死了。但是，你知道，英雄之死。所以这真是最完美的结局，不是吗？哈拉尔·哈德拉达死于1066年，这一年基本上，传统上来说，它是维京时代的谢幕。他是一个
is a perfect figure to, to, to bring it to an end because he's a guy who dies in England, like so many Viking adventurers before him, but he's made his name. He's made his money in the East. Yeah. And also because his career kind of sums up all the he's he in some ways he's quite
完美的人物，来为这个时代画上句号，因为他是一个死在英国的人，就像在他之前的许多维京冒险家一样，但他已经在东方打响了名声。他赚到了财富。是的。而且因为他的职业生涯在某种程度上概括了所有的……他在某些方面是一个
a sort of out of time figure isn't he i mean he's these places are becoming kingdoms yeah you know they are becoming more settled uh slightly more ordered i suppose they are christian now rather than pagan and of course with 1066 the anglo-saxon nobility go off and replace the Scandinavians as the Varangians. They do. So actually the irony is that actually people who could have conceivably fought on opposite sides at the Battle of Stamford Bridge could well end up serving five years later in the same army for the Emperor constantinople i mean i think that's the part of the fascination of this whole subject of the vikings in the east is that sense of um oh vikings and romans you know yeah people out of time running up with one another or vikings you know in uh in the caspian sea um it does have that kind of slight element of fantasy about it well that's why for example
有点与时代格格不入的人物，不是吗？我的意思是，这些地方正在变成王国。是的，你知道的，它们正在变得更加安定，稍微更有秩序一些，我猜他们现在是基督徒而不是异教徒了，当然随着1066年的到来，盎格鲁-撒克逊贵族走出来，取代了斯堪的纳维亚人成为瓦兰吉亚人。确实如此。所以实际上，讽刺的是，在斯坦福桥战役中本可能在对立双方作战的人，很可能五年后在君士坦丁堡皇帝的同一支军队中服役。我的意思是，我认为这是整个“东方维京人”主题中最令人着迷的部分，那种……哦，维京人和罗马人，你知道的，是的，不同时代的人狭路相逢，或者维京人在里海，这确实带有一点奇幻的色彩。所以这就是为什么，例如，
michael crichtonon wrote a book called The Death Eaters or something like that. I can't remember. The Eaters of Light or something like that. With Ibn Fadlan as the character. And that was later adapted for the cinema as The Thirteenth Warrior, I think. And Rosemary Sutcliffe has written about it.
迈克尔·克莱顿写了一本书叫《食尸鬼》或者类似的名字。我记不清了。《食光者》或者类似的名字。里面的角色是伊本·法德兰。后来这部作品被改编成电影《第十三勇士》，我想是这样的。罗斯玛丽·萨特克利夫也写过关于它的书。
And Henry Treese. Henry Treese, yeah, the writer of Mikl-Lagarde. It's a permanent... It's exactly as you say, it's got a slight science fiction quality to it in that it's Arabs, Romans, Vikings, all kind of... All mixed up. All mixed up, exactly. And I think that's one way, even now,
还有亨利·特里斯。亨利·特里斯，是的，米克拉加德的作家。这是一个永恒的……正如你所说的那样，它带有一种轻微的科幻色彩，因为它是阿拉伯人、罗马人、维京人，全都被……全都混杂在一起。全混在一起，没错。我认为这也是为什么，即使在现在，
when we mention to people we could do this as a subject, you can see that people are kind of excited about it because it's the ultimate exotic adventure story, I think. Yeah. And as we said right at the beginning of the first episode, which seems a very long time ago, it's also very, very politically sensitive. And yet, I mean, Tom, obviously there is no answer to that Russian-Ukrainian question with this. I mean, it obviously forms, it's the foundational moment of both countries' history books. There are statues of these characters in Ukraine and in Russia, understandably. There's a statue of Vladimir in London.
当我们向人们提起我们可以把这个作为一个主题时，你可以看到人们对此感到兴奋，因为它终究是一个异国情调的冒险故事，我认为是的。正如我们在第一集刚开始时所说的那样，那似乎是很久以前的事了，它也非常、非常具有政治敏感性。然而，汤姆，显然那个俄乌问题并没有一个明确的答案。我的意思是，它显然构成了两国历史书的基础时刻。在乌克兰和俄罗斯，都有这些人物的雕像，这是可以理解的。伦敦甚至有一尊弗拉基米尔的雕像。
Is there? Yeah. Why? Just down from Notting Hill. Is it outside a church or something? It must be something to do with that, yeah. I mean, you can completely understand why they both lay claim. And obviously I'm not going to
真的吗？是的。为什么？就在诺丁山附近。是在教堂外面还是什么地方？那一定跟这有什么关系，是的。我的意思是，你完全可以理解为什么他们两个都声称拥有这段历史。显然我不会
be mad to sort of pick sides in this sort of political debate. We're not a political podcast, but they both clearly do have different histories, Russia and Ukraine, but they come from the same place. I think that's fair to say.
傻到在这类政治辩论中选边站。我们不是一个政治播客，但他们显然都有不同的历史——俄罗斯和乌克兰，但他们都源自同一个地方。我认为这样说很公平。
Anyway, right, we're just wittering now. Great stuff. This has been a podcast devoted to people going to the sea, taking to the water, trading, stabbing each other in the back. And our next episode, by coincidence, is going to be on smuggling. Perfect link, Tom.
总之，好吧，我们现在只是在瞎扯。太棒了。这是一个专注于人们出海、水上贸易、背后捅刀子的播客。而我们的下一集，巧合的是，将是关于走私的。完美的承接，汤姆。
Well done. So we will see you then. Yeah, we'll see you for Smugglers next time bye-bye thanks for listening to the rest is history for bonus episodes early access ad-free listening and access to our chat community. Please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment.
干得好。那么我们到时候见。好的，我们下次“走私者”见，拜拜。感谢收听《历史的其余部分》，想要获取更多单集、抢先收听、无广告体验以及我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。那是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐滑铁卢》。
It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝八卦的好去处。在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告节目、独家单集以及优先购买现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。